hello and welcome to still playing a
number with us nom rapist we don't know
and to be get the Vienna f4
okay yeah this is a move 95 as a normal
continuation here that leads to
something so some strange positions but
I always wondered why e4 isn't isn't any
good here it probably is okay it leads
to positions from the fork Bri mature
fake bi and this is the counter gambit
not sure if this is from a german player
on from an english-speaking player
probably fake bear is correct this is
a.45 f45 looks a lot like this your
blood should black should have a very
good compensation here Wow okay so he's
worried about something coming to give
40 k 8 looks like the most normal move
here
is it is probably not GE to Bishop t2
castling long this is the thing do I
somehow get an attack on the screen
going night a 62 before would be cool
chat okay I probably start with this na
GE too and now hmm 986 he will probably
just take 97 to be six he might might
manage the specialty to Y or maybe I can
do a g6 and just insisting what he has
got G form and then you probably will
pledge if all night h5 is a very direct
way of threatening queen age 5 but then
so weird
I need to open up very quickly here my
dear stood fatigue school not 27 I'd
like to take on c6 with the noid the d5
pawn is obstructing my queen sensor so
I'm trying to get rid of it yeah so here
b5 it's sitting him I think this was a
mistake Bishop detune if tonight move
got Bishop a six and he has to sacrifice
the Queen for some small pieces hi Scott
bishops you form didn't see that move
coming
hanging by a thread yeah but he does I
just hang hang on I don't have a good
movement how to believe i know it's a
temple on that bloody bishop you will
see a tactical solution here afterward
that's really unnerving and now he's got
a good position after canceling on great
great great great you can just cancel
long i don't see the deal I did or take
further take first and maybe it's not so
easy okay if it takes on c6 do I have
something don't really see anything good
this is the thing 27 maybe still
stopping him from canceling probably or
cancel any way for some tactic
I get to take c6 and then I think okay
his screen is tied to e2
that's Epona I have that feeling that
you can maybe someone give up the give
up the night and like long castles
Queenie to Queenie to okay to Bishop
before some miracle stuff this one okay
so Bishop takes is going Bishop them hmm
okay yeah but ok i cannot i have to take
what I'm trying to say and now we cancel
it's okay because this Bishop Hanks yeah
well played time morning thank you I'm
still taking you can do something on the
night but maybe you can even play 95 it
looks extremely loose but might be
possible yeah i'll just be three
so why is this working show me
don't see why
Oh create create check Queen B seven I
can just develop white resigns okay
that's a bit too much oh wow I was
really a bit frustrated here because it
must be a nice position ready we will
get this him age three check yeah okay
so this is a critical position okay the
computer gives this as even stronger
yeah threatening be five before and the
bat tick he wants to check or that wants
to check this is very strong actually I
think it's this kind of thing yeah
that's very strong the engine gives a
whinny already invite us weekend a lot
in with the foh three check care um and
I went here probably not a bad solution
andrew wants to go a six a four and then
c6
Casey sexy play Bishop t2 yeah and b5
should win but it didn't it didn't
because I played this okay yeah Bishop a
six is a lot stronger okay just do I
simply didn't didn't see that Bishop c4
was coming it still win some 94 wins for
for me why exactly because night f2 is
so strong hmm Wow and thn age 4 is
strong and check to take each one at the
end yeah okay didn't see it and the end
it still likes my position ok here it
gives night bd7 as winning can I thought
I have to get rid of the pawn but this
is this is certainly true it's not it's
not promoting and I have this ok now
it's still no it's a game again and now
I thought just be three and well it's it
wasn't clear to me what this is what
this is all about the computer actually
thinks I'm a lot bad of it I wasn't
showing the game this is of course a bad
piece and I have ideas 94 95 and so on
yeah this is just should win from black
young check he's got got nothing for him
for the material yeah good bit of a
wacky game an awesome guy I didn't take
my chances down that
would have been neither the spot of
Bishop a 6-2 win Amir Len okay well
thanks for watching